let's kick it off let's go that's it
that's it that's that hitter you know
who that is baby that's Tess stiva
starlight
there you go
[Music]
there you go girl then you go Big Dawg
they're all no extra scarf put on extra
scarf we getting naughty we are getting
naughty thank you guys for being here
this past Thursday this is this is an
episode that is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block at 1811 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles on the way to
the beach you know get that hitter I
also want to let you know that hey did
you know this past weekend is now
available on Spotify Spotify is making
it easy for you to stream this podcast
and many others like it on your mobile
device desktop app and smart speaker
open the app on mobile or desktop click
on the Browse channel and then click on
the podcast section take me with you
wherever you go thanks to Spotify play
me for the children leave me in a room
alone speaker and put your grandmother
in there your senior citizen grandfather
in there in a wheelchair
and put me on the speaker next to them
and let them get that vibe because we
write here slinging this vibe real real
quick we're about to get into the
episode and I want to thank you guys for
being here with me we have Nick Davis's
in studio today Nick something oh how
are you I'm really well then I want to
thank you so much in addition to Chris
Perez who isn't here today but who's
helping produce you're here today and we
got our first guest in oh yeah Jay Mohr
I know and you've worked with Jay before
you've been in studio with him before
yeah yeah over at the Adam Carolla Show
he was a fan favorite there it brings
characters and great pod yeah he's a
wild animal man and I'm so excited we're
gonna get to him in just a second and
thank you for being here with us Nick I
want to let you guys notice a couple of
upcoming dates April 6th and 7th I'll be
in Tampa Florida at the Attic at Rock
Brothers brewing and that's almost sold
out April 20th and 21st I'll be in
Hasbrouck Heights New Jersey at bananas
or bananas as they say in Spanish
June 15th and 16th that Yuk Yuk's up
there in Calgary Canada so if you
Canadian get out there boy and July 6th
through the 8th at levity live in Oxnard
and I'm so grateful you guys would be
here all tickets are available at theof
on comm / tour t oh you are and we'll be
launching that dark arts tour very soon
here as soon as we get this dang website
put together but we have J morning today
I'm excited and I'm so grateful for you
guys for being here with me and if I've
not been talking into this the whole
time Nick I feel bad I think they know
you're you're talking to him there all
right okay all right guys I just want to
thank you so much we're gonna go now we
just recorded the episode with Jay and
then I did this part after to be honest
with you and uh and we had Jay Mohr in
and this our first our first guest we
had uneven Stephen a while back that
gentleman I met at the DMV and he came
in here with some issues boy he had that
you know I mean his eyeballs wasn't you
know just in the Dead Sea he was out
there on that fire water and then we had
another gentleman you know mr. Roger
Robb but this is our first real guest in
the studio here and welcome and we were
happy to have mr. Jay Mohr these pipes
go let's go in oh yeah and you are
you're iris huh Irish German Scottish so
you might not make it might not make it
let man there's a plane crash I'm
walking out and I'm not gonna be like
that [ __ ] Lynyrd Skynyrd I got shot
in somebody's front door yeah that's one
of the best stories that nobody tells
what happens to Iggy so we're here with
uh with Jay Mohr hi we're live I think
thank you guys for joining us um so
Lynyrd Skynyrd died well he did not die
for the band a bunch of members died
there was a plane crash
yeah Skynyrd and a couple dudes died one
guy survived he like a broken pelvis
broken back broken legs and he walked it
like a farmhouse mm-hmm like there's
like clockwork horns it's been a
horrible accident and the guy shot him
Wow
and he died that way just a so he
survived all the way till the door
that's I would be a guy I'd show
the gates swinging doesn't I'd be like
you mother I just [ __ ] survived the
plane are you [ __ ] kidding me
little buckshot all through my body you
get shot in the chest with buckshot it's
in your legs like there yeah from the
inside yeah I think that's the kind of
thing I bet it right when you get shot
by die but you start to itch because
it's yeah that hot we're talking
specifically gunshot yeah twenty-two guy
like you would blink off a 22 year you
could shake off 22 you could still drive
to the CVS and get what your wife needs
unless it was the Mossad then they put
it up your butt
what is that the Israeli Secret Service
uh uh they get into bed like they dress
up oh you don't know about operation
wrath of God uh huh after the 72
olympics massacre Golda Meir after they
told her what happened the Prime
Minister said send the boys and then the
Mossad the last guy they killed I think
was nineteen ninety six seventy two we
answered his cell phone hello is this a
but you know whatever and he goes yes
boom so he's head off with a cell phone
and so the Mossad is like a dark art
they're like a Dark Arts army kind of
for Israel it's their Secret Service
they're like Marines yeah but like
Netanyahu was one and like they would
literally dress up in burkas walk around
like women for a day and then crawl into
bed and then the husband would come home
they put a 22 in his [ __ ] pull the
trigger six empty uh and they get back
in the book they'd be back in Israel in
like six hours did that almost makes me
some part of that maybe like a mildly
sexually turned you're holding it yeah
you are you are adjusting I don't know
what that was but this is Theo von here
and we listen to his podcast yeah and
thank you for joining us thank you John
Ferguson more we're uh said that like no
John Ferguson more you know you're the
first guests that we've ever had why is
that well we have gang gang we had a one
man who had some issues uh who I met at
the DMV one time but he hasn't I don't
know I can't believe he was available oh
yeah he came the hot ticket he was
shining mannequins I mean it seemed like
somebody just you know just hidden just
electricity in his eyes boy when he
showed up he was pretty bent out this
man Steven and uh and I have enough to
get a hold of him I've called him a
couple times and then we had another
dude this guy's kind of an older wig
a guy and that was this guy named Roger
rod and if you know him he's comedian
it's my rap name is oh yeah I'm debate I
go back and forth between parallel oh
it's good parallelogram yeah of the
program what um it's actually by the way
that had no thought other than that
moment I know I want you guys to thank
my fake rat names I got was
parallelogram or let it was that bad
I've just you know off the top my dome
kid mine honestly dude and this is like
I wanted to be white [ __ ] back in the
day
but and I know that that's kind of a you
know I mean now it's like you know I
would hope you're all out of [ __ ] at
this point yeah okay are you like me
Theo von
all right like when a celebrity
apologizes you'll ask me my like Bill
Maher's apology and raise me really the
joke was perfect
yeah the joke was perfect structurally
contextually and it was encounter to a
creepy [ __ ] white guy saying come on
down we'll put you to work in the fields
yeah he goes what what did you say look
what you work in the fields yeah he goes
I'm I'm a house [ __ ] yeah perfect yeah
and then Twitter gets going and
Twitter's the death bottom line is HBO
goes if you don't apologize you can say
goodbye to whatever million dollars so
he does the apology but the thing is
[ __ ] who is that apology forget
either a racist yeah it's for HBO
oh I think that he's probably just as
racist as some people all right look I
don't think a comedian can really even
be racist this is right this is our
tribe gays and blacks and like women
like you're a homophobe ugh homo I'm in
show business like are you talking about
I can't be right I don't think like it's
just a but the more you defend that the
more you seem like a guy that's
defending what he believes in the
opposite yeah it's like you're up
against you all often feel out here like
I'm up against a mountain but I was
talking about friend about this
yesterday like there's also this weird
vibe that like all gay people are like
the friendliest people a lot of gay
dudes that I know even my buddies are
[ __ ] yeah so judgmental your outfits
a little matchy-matchy you know yeah
well that's everybody I mean so we're
right it's everybody like that in this
car like that and of itself is you and I
having a bit of a racist conversation
because we're saying that like
I do this when it's society when it's
everybody society are just [ __ ] dicks
okay so then do you think that for some
reason then that like first of all lower
your [ __ ] boys need automate okay all
right do you think that for some reason
I then top that I will like so think so
based in that that like if everybody's
just an [ __ ] but I guess maybe it's
like gay guys don't get it's like they
get sometimes this past that they're not
[ __ ] just because they're gay like
they get this shield of armor
maybe I don't do assumptions man maybe
I'm not airing you out to dry but maybe
yeah but I do know there's what I know
about gay guys they love the [ __ ] yeah
but they don't necessarily need a [ __ ]
to like get what they need
yeah like they have mouths and like
mutual masturbation parties and stuff
like that
do they really I hope so where at I'm
gonna find out we will be there just
mutual masturbation there that'd be a
great of a great movie two dudes they go
undercover no like a gay man's um you
know sex house or something Oh crisis
yeah no yes and they like they have to
not get [ __ ] that's the rule now this
would be a good thing different
fraternity rush millions yes yes if you
get [ __ ] you lose all the money if you
get [ __ ] you everything but yeah can I
blow a guy why would you ever ask me
that no I don't know like in stripes
when he goes last question its standard
or either one of you homosexuals know
like flaming and he'll dreamers goes no
but we're willing to learn Bill Murray
goes would they send us someplace
special for that I haven't seen that
movie man like black the stereotypes I
think are stereotypes cuz they're true
Irish people are drunk I'm alcoholic
black people don't tip right uh
stereotypically though I was a waiter or
a black couple came at the end of your
shift you're like I'm not I'm not
[ __ ] staying I'm not gonna chop up
pineapple slices for this guy's blended
drink yeah and I'm give me a quarter ago
that's for you my man yeah now every
friend I have goes I you've been to
dinner with me I an incredible and they
are like incredible temper so it's some
[ __ ] I held on from my past
yeah that's the thing sometimes I wonder
if they're just things that I hold onto
from a long time ago that like I don't
know if they just don't serve me anymore
I don't know I can't even tell I would
say none of it serves you or me from a
long time ago well yeah we got [ __ ] up
in our living rooms how tall you I'm
probably I'm so that's that's weird
that's it probably yeah but I haven't
checked myself in probably 15 years
are you sure yep maybe I had a growth
spurt at 32 or if my grandfather grew
two inches in his 50s in his early 50s
what was he watching I don't know what
he was watching I mean he was probably I
don't know what he was doing but he grew
two inches in his 50s and here's the
crazy part oh you talking about cop I
thought yeah no I mean in his height and
he and they go really low and then I
kind of come in high different
frequencies with the UH but this man he
um and he didn't like his wife anymore
when he grew taller how crazy and they
were in love before did she have female
pattern baldness serious question and
that is the first time you could see
like oh my god I don't think so I just
stupid head I could look at him but I
think from certain angles certain people
are prettier you know so often it makes
a great point it makes you think that
like if yeah the love of your life or
1/2 inch shorter then you guys might
hate each other because you'd be
catching that other optic of her you
know you might be coming in at that hot
46 when you were a year in love at about
a forty eight days um yeah I'm 47 years
old
I've never even entertained or had any
notion of this particular conversation
congratulation I'm serious like I've
never in my life entertained this idea
that at a different height you wouldn't
be in love with who you're in love with
it's really fascinating yeah my angles
different optics well they fell out of
love me and it cost him his love of his
life you know but good ostomy got new
[ __ ] how old was he 52 I believe hey
I'm 47 yeah I hope you know all I've
cialis I gonna remember the Good Humor
man had that thing would change on his
hip like cialis like that if I took five
milligrams when I hit the hit the comedy
store last night the [ __ ] I got makes my
leg sweat I got some stuff from India
right now and my pants will be wet dude
by about an hour half into that pill but
why why did your legs I don't know I
think it's flushing that's the side
effect people to understand what
flushing means it's all the liquid
leaves your body
except semen and blood oh really yeah
that's what you like Pitt your cheeks
get red yeah yeah my lips get hard and I
can't talk that good cuz all the
moisture lives and like you get a
cottonmouth and you just keep pissing
and [ __ ] and pissing and [ __ ]
like what's going on you just sit tight
they gonna run he dumped with a boner
like I gotta get in there like I'm
trying to [ __ ] my Agra I prefer cialis
cuz viagra is just like oh it's too
strong can't get a shirt on and off of a
viagra
I like that too intense I had a so I had
cialis last night I was on the phone
with you I'm away to the pharmacy to
pick it up and they go that'll be $600
and I go well I don't have $600 how many
pills are in there yeah so they go ten I
go how much for a pill and the
pharmacist goes I'll give you
oh really so I ate it there and then I
went on in front of her now I didn't
realize how all boy she handed me the
bottle with one pill rattling around
yeah does any old drug addict knows like
no boy no man I need two packs I make no
sound as I walked through checkpoint
charlie there and I just swallowed it I
went home my girlfriend made dinner and
then um did you guys have sex after or
no I didn't attack you late but it was
it was the longest I've had sex and
maybe three years Wow because I have
erectile dysfunction yeah bad oh I've
been there look most are good as keitel
as opposed to good yeah
is it bad as opposed to good well movie
I wonder what that is us William Wallace
that's correct
movie William no it's uh what is it
movie Nick you know it William Jennings
Bryant is it unusual suspects no Harvey
Keitel was not in there now where it was
Reservoir Dogs where Tim Roth is shot
and then Steve Buscemi goes holy [ __ ] is
it bad as opposed to good oh it's a
Larry I don't know that many movies like
I'm trying to think of some of my
favorite movies our dream team have you
seen that maybe what is it it's about
Allen Klein no what's that guy's name
Michael Keaton gets in a mental health
facility and then they get out one day
they get like a leave of absence I
remember that steal a van because their
boys in it yeah I do remember that that
movie was good
michael keaton yeah he did a movie
called I think it's called life or my
life and when the script came out I was
like 24 obviously was gonna read for his
part but they're like this is Michael
Keaton's Oscar Lee and the script it was
it's when he finds out he's dying and he
keeps making videos for his on his wife
Nicole Kidman and he keeps making videos
for the kid huh and it was and the
movies great and they just like we don't
give a [ __ ]
was it heartbreaking and beautiful yeah
it was great but sometimes people don't
get nominated like Robert Duvall every
time he opens his mouth you're like
eating it nominated forget low yeah time
to get low
yeah like Keitel in a bad lieutenant
like he calls Jesus a rat [ __ ] and a
hallucination naked and they Jack's
often like some girls car that he pulls
over like you know you got a taillight
out give us a [ __ ] like what hey don't
talk back to me we'll bring you in okay
it's like what do you guys do to get
nominated around here Wow guys punching
his clown in traffic I don't know if it
Matt I think it's yeah I think it's just
you know they got these upper echelons
out here and you got to get in you know
you got to be pulling on somebody's you
got to be pulling on the right skirt out
here there's some people get nominated
that we don't even know where they are I
don't think there's first of all you
have to nominate yourself you know like
I really cuz I was like how come I never
been nominated for like an Emmy and I
was on Ghost Whisperer did you feel like
you had a role that was deserving a
nomination action this action absolutely
I thought that was one of the best shows
of all time and it's not like look at me
look at me it's the what I got to say
was so astound and now like pression it
was all like Weinstein stuff like Salma
Hayek just slaps me in the face 40 times
one episode I'm like you don't remember
when I came to town you put your penis
in a box I wanted to play puppet show
I'm like now that's a medical condition
bang bang and like that show is great
but you have to nominate yourself you
you have to send money with your packet
and then they tell you if you get
nominated or not and it's like so that
means Kelsey Grammer has been nominated
in like 12 times and he did it every
time you just keep [ __ ] so much
malcontent
bro relax like we see you you're Kelsey
Grammer
yeah yeah back off Julia louis-dreyfus
okay
yeah I mean I guess but I guess at a
certain point if you're in that
Hollywood ladder on the show today so we
can air this out finally that's the
that's part of it like I got a Grammy
nomination but I had to put it in myself
for my for comedy I'm like you have to
get a publicist team and you got to go
[ __ ] it they only make like what 200
albums a year or they make 200 albums a
year there's no way right I'm an
optimist I'm like well there's only 200
and I got to think a hundred of those
are just [ __ ] yeah so how many
people are actually cobbling together
the resources to go check this out yeah
and they only picked five and it was the
year I got nominated was louis c.k
George Lopez Lisa Lampanelli
Craig Fergus if I lose great because
they're all great Lisa Benelli was on my
podcast more stories and she was
nominated before and she lost the flight
of the conchords and she goes those
[ __ ]
she goes that album 16 minutes long goes
those crispy Kiwi flecks they're so
stupid and dry I go if I lost the flight
of the conchords I'd be tipping tables
over yeah like well it's been three
years making a good album and I got a
songs already like that's why we don't
cave yeah great I just made that's not
their song by the way and if it is they
can have it do you uh I'm getting I'm
gonna get back to this erectile
disfunction thing man because I've you
know I've certainly I've struggled in
some some of that dick work sometimes
for me just two ways I think you get it
and that's a well three ways mental
self-sabotage like getting up in your
own head drugs or being abused mm-hmm so
which one was it for you I realize I
just turned the tables on you no it's
okay uh you know I like thinking about
this stuff because it's like thinking
about your dick well if you took a
cialis at The Comedy Store oh I just
took it to feel good man because your
legs get sweaty that's not feel good
this also gets kind of like my penis
seemed like it just ate something you
know like it just ate like Thanksgiving
or something and then you go home and
you're like jerk off to like porn I know
I'm late sometimes I just lay there on
my hard dick man and just feel like a
genie yeah
that's princess in the pee kind of I
like that reference you know it's weird
when I watched
we're not sponsored I didn't watch any
last night I'm like eight is that like
oh yeah
they don't yell oh [ __ ] me step daddy
they leave the step out
thank thankfully well it's almost I
think Father's Day should become
stepfathers day it's almost at that
point I feel like we're the stepfathers
don't get any credit and I've always
thought that have you ever been a
stepfather no but my oldest boy he's 15
he's got a stepdad who's tremendous
really absolutely [ __ ] tremendous but
now at first were you nervous about like
when that stepdad kind of shows up or
did you feel like like the first time
you're gonna go meet the guy did you put
on like a special shirt or anything like
that I put on yeah my comedy show I got
Gabriel Iglesias a Hawaiian shirt and I
just laughed at all my I know what's up
Gabe I you know what honestly is mom
being a single mom I knew I didn't know
him but there's just the signal and the
noise and I just sort of knew it was a
steadying thing and I have a book called
no wonder my parents drank and there's a
whole chapter about the step parents
like the number one whammy you can throw
it a kid it's it's either the pant the
band-aid the panacea the bridge or it's
the reason you [ __ ] strip like make
like that's it there's only a couple
options like clean your [ __ ] room get
your [ __ ] together [ __ ] you're like
I'm sixteen who the [ __ ] is this guy
that I hear having sex with my mom like
I'm gonna kill him and then there's guys
that are just steady and great and
that's what this guy was and he is and
he's beautiful yeah like my sons a lot
of my sons great qualities are because
of this guy and that's you got it you
got to swallow a lot of [ __ ] pride
himself to go
this guy this guy did some hard wiring
inside this this laptop and I did a good
job does it make you feel like you that
that was something you should have done
like is there moments you're like man
this are you're just grateful you just
find just gratitude like I'm go ahead
it's a good question specific to the
situation because I retreat well I get
under the porch real quick man and I'd
split custody with his mom it was any
every time he was with me it's just like
when do I go back to my mom's whenever I
go back to meet him and I saw a
therapist about it she goes you're
battling a
biblical chord you got to give this up
like you're battling and he was a
parasite she was a host yeah this goes
back this is intergalactic you're
fighting the universe before alloy stir
you can't be can't battle that correct
and one day he got off the bus and it
was like the second day I had him and he
goes when do I go to my mom's I said I
could take you right now and he goes
okay like real excited and then then he
like reeled it in goes I mean I but he
already let it out and I drove into his
mom's and I said if you miss me call me
okay but it wasn't that kind as I'm
saying now yeah and I let a year go by
damn because I was like and that's you
know I'm an alcohol and I'm in a lot of
A's aana a whole yeah I'm in there and
it's like my alcoholic brain was let's
see how they do without me hmm and they
did just fine without me
which is crippling if you let it cave in
on you mm-hmm so after about a year I
saw him and it was entirely too long and
that's you know essentially like I lost
a kid because I lost a kid when you saw
him that first time after that year like
what was that moment like that had to be
really heavy oh I was in an abusive
marriage I'm picking up your access
right I was in an abusive marriage just
a little bit that I do
I'm from now Brian Snipes from
Natchitoches I'm grace [ __ ] corner in
the lead man you know I wanted Alabama
birth I was gonna go to LSU but they
sent special teams coach of my army I
look like [ __ ] gunner do you man John
Prine Snipes 18 that's what's happening
I went out lamb you know why dick Saban
came up that dirt driveway hit 104
degrees you know not gonna get hot as
[ __ ] man and we watching tape my
grandmama go would you like some sweet
tea goes and he says no thank you I said
oh [ __ ] man I strike two minutes you'll
turn on a sweet tea man right you know
saying you from there and then check out
dude we watching tape with me and I
[ __ ] this dude up man he catch the
ball separated [ __ ] from his shoes I
take the ball to the house he stopped
Fanning himself we go out to go watch
some of that sweet tears that should
give this dude Oscar man so I had to go
to Alabama just out of respect for that
game man out of respect [ __ ] when I play
special team they're gonna bid I don't
kick I know kicker man a special shoes
and h-e a UX dude not a lot of letters
in some of the neighborhoods down there
not know need him he said like do we had
a black kid oh my god I've already quit
so dense was his name right and it was
spelled though like the word COI NCI nd
NCE I think I'll take your word for it
yeah and I was like oh quit kawin and
he's like no no Quinn siddhis and I was
like well everybody pasta we all lose
here no win I mean we all win but it was
wildly I don't think if we had a girl in
Kizzy Lorant at my school used to beat
the [ __ ] out of every dude right and she
was this tough girl and you know she did
my girl
um but uh and go um no straight up I
think hundred percent black and she used
to I mean she would beat any dude up and
then now though years later she has like
her son is like his he's like one of the
top running backs in the whole country
he's tough kid
and he seemed like a sweat school to
coming to the high school down there in
Covington Louisiana man why do you think
you got oh I don't want to flip it on
you again so I was in a no no I want to
know it's about that because that kind
of got me like I'm imagine and like
rubbing your penis that's because a
these pants are tight and I'm probably
nervous dude why you nervous to friends
hang out talk you know I'm not nervous
like that I'm nervous like externa dude
I think just being in a room with two
men that this that of this size of it
out that's the size of a room and being
in a room with two men you must be great
on auditions you know I'm not good at
all yeah yeah there unless you did I get
so [ __ ] nervous man I can't even you
every David Mamet true and false uh uh
you need to say that I would never say
that unless you needed to when you go
into an heroic Glengarry Glen Ross
speed-the-plow and a Spanish person
everybody but he goes uh he writes when
you walk into an audition you you must
know you're everyone in the room is your
moral and intellectual inferior because
at some time they had the bravery to do
what you're doing and they took the desk
mmm say the lines as best you can and
next time saying better wow I was like
damn where were you the first 500
auditions David Mamet that's robert e
lee stuff right there well I'd like to
keep it north of the mason-dixon line I
just
with the winner yeah I'm all about the
angles right now yeah are you really
well I'm not gonna back a lizard-like
factory bill belichick sourpuss
yeah I have stopped in a stupid accident
it's insulting to you and your brood oh
I don't think it's bad man I mean I had
to do to my neighborhood I just feel
like the listeners are like how do you
have a rect I'll disfunction go back go
back go back go back
Joseph's marriage well look man I mean
he will then get back to the question
then here's the thing the person that I
was in the marriage with would never I
mean under penalty of perjury and truth
serum in their veins would never think
that they were abusive right it's like a
passive narcissism words but do you okay
so so you can't but after a while you
realize you can't there's nothing you
can do about that right I'm sure you
tried yeah I well I realized it early
that I couldn't do anything about it and
accountability that's what really makes
me crazy that's a big trigger for me
like in recovery like right people
aren't accountable because my program is
all about accountability and what I did
even you know when I was going through
my resentments my sponsor said like well
how are you self-seeking how are you so
how are you selfish while you held this
resentment for somebody didn't show up
to marriage and I was like I wasn't he
goes that's impossible I'm like no you
weren't there like yeah
and I'm telling you now to your face I
wasn't like I ran myself inside out
because but if you knew if you knew that
she wasn't gonna be able to meet you at
this place you wanted her to meet you at
and you kept trying then what you know
not to like but cuz I could see myself
doing that I had a girlfriend like that
is the question I like this question
don't don't be afraid okay then if you
knew that she couldn't meet you there
and you kept trying but you knew you
knew in that place in your brain that
knows it all and is probably right that
you knew she couldn't meet you there
then at that point isn't is there
something just kind of ill or sick about
continuing to hope that she can yeah
there is but I think overriding that is
I took vows man I take those vows
seriously right till death do us part
and I waited for me to able to be able
to identify the
has been a death here mmm death do us
part right what we knew died and I
discovered the well beneath the well
inside of me cuz I people go like hey
you leave no stone unturned I'm like
there's no more stones man i ground them
to dust they're gone there's no stones I
got there yeah I try everything you know
it's a bit like I know there's three
years where every time you go to the
bathroom you're like this is impossible
yeah but it ain't cuz you're living it
and you're like physically you get sick
like mentally and then you file for
divorce I filed for divorce and I don't
wanna get too into it at a privacy for
her and yeah cuz I love her I do love
her very the opposite of love isn't hate
its indifference I'm nowhere near and
different to like any ex I've ever had
because I go all in I think we're a lot
alike like you love all the way but then
you hurt all the way and the people in
this world are very afraid they like to
swim with their hand on the side of the
pool and then wish it doesn't work out
they're like hey daddy told you told you
is too deep out there but they don't
ever love like you love I I don't know I
think I'm in-between because you say
that hand on the side of the pool thing
you wouldn't be an addict if you knew
the side of the pool you you you only
live in liminal space and deep water
that's just that you're a great white
shark man you you couldn't be an addict
if you got your hand the side of the
pool yeah you know breath you're [ __ ]
Darryl Strawberry story ya doing blowing
you know [ __ ] brave you gotta be to
just have that night and just go [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it there's like 18 [ __ ] it yeah
that puts you further into the dragon's
lair
and I was [ __ ] loving it man that's
right miss and that's where you get that
love is in the deep water healthy or
unhealthy when you're having sex and you
make that connection that's so goddamn
deep yeah that's the connection that
ain't that's not the greatest [ __ ] you
ever had that's the greatest [ __ ]
combined with somebody looking you in
your eye and saying like [ __ ] me daddy
and they're like not incestuous yeah you
will protect me you have the answers I
won't eat so you [ __ ] get home Wow
like that's deep [ __ ] like that's deep
water that's a brave woman or like when
you hurt you hurt all the way like I've
I've had the pressure where I didn't get
out of bed I pissed my own bed my dog
[ __ ] in my bed mmm I didn't give a [ __ ]
that's a good ending my phone vibrated
it was one of the coaches I you know I
assistant coach wrestling and the coach
at a previous school goes I need you to
start practice to them and I'm like
alright bang outta bed it saved me so
the erectile disfunction was me when
you're married to somebody that's Buber
sexual and a [ __ ] Bardo knockout no
one's hotter on earth period to this day
like I had lady had it all freakin I'm
watching porn a jackoff I want at my
mind mind wanders and I think about her
I'm like oh god my buddies to jerk off
then mail it to his ex-wife for like a
year and a half I respect that what
would he put it on like a slide so she
can look at on her microscope no he just
put it on some paper and but then she
just gets paper but she knows though oh
that's one of my favorite but she knows
well you start to know at a certain
point the first time you get it I think
you could think it's snot or something
or somebody you know how to snail in
there and then they took it out but then
that second or third time you're like
this is busy down in like Louisiana like
in that mailbox in the envelope I can't
imagine oh my god like the ad for the
sea monkeys come out the kids on a bike
guy wearing a crown but you say like she
knows you said like Louisiana style like
the same sentence in Jersey
she knows you know she knows so you know
they're very similar a lot of times
people will say a Louisiana accent if
you have like a real strong you know
like where yet you know that stuff that
this sounds like New Jersey a lot of
times but I don't believe you've ever
heard that in your life yeah much times
people be like you from New Jersey I
think maybe those people stand too close
to the oven or yeah those people might
be bad off look I know I may not be the
tallest hyena at the world atlas hmm but
I got obsessed last night because I'm
one of your stand-up thing girls
watching you said I'm not the prior -
bull in the bowl drawer oh yeah and I
realize that I look to my girlfriend I
go that's what I want to do a Theo cuz
you can literally do anything make no
sense but no matter what it is the
person was exactly what you're saying
yeah I'm not the softest couch on the
fish and run but you know like literally
anything works yeah dude I'm the only
yeah I'm not the most crippled guy at
the [ __ ] at the carnival it's hard to
uh it's hard to actually come up with
nonsense it is it's like Reggie Watts
you watching you're like oh wow that's
the only just talk nonsense like trying
to talk nonsense
see I you get the sentence the real
million dollar you run short Harlan
Williams does it extremely well man yes
but he is the luxury of doing it again
yeah
and again like let's go watch Peggy Sue
put a kayak in the toilet upside down
and go for a ride I got a pet squirrel
on my head with shampoo bottles you know
it's name is bag yeah is anytime it's
sexy like okay Benedict Arnold
you know yeah hey you bet buddy I'm okay
paper bag on my head a gas station but
it turns out it was gout yeah I [ __ ]
love you Harlan is a joyous guy yeah so
you had the mayor got married man I love
this kind of stuff because I'm afraid to
get into a frayed period is no that
doesn't serve you no yeah afraid like
you're a comic you're one of the best
comics I've seen in my life yeah thanks
man ever throw one of years no you are
good in the you know you gotta look good
and you got to realize that your upper
1% period that's not subjective yeah
nickel tell a deep I don't even like you
they Nix our producer today yeah they
don't know who Nick is your audience you
know that transfer first time we've ever
had Nick Oh big first day kids it's a
big first man do you have it's a strong
like bull it's like 14 little kids out
there they all yours I don't know who
those little children are but think
about it's a patina thanks for playing
along have you ever have you ever
ejaculated inside of a woman in hopes to
get her pregnant just out of spite
all right no don't answer that objection
you added out of spite as he started
going with his answer so if you wanted
that like a baby I know what you're
doing and I want that with withdrawal
yeah okay to be a lawyer is great you'd
be like and that's why you gave her AIDS
object withdrawn like then withdrawn
don't worry about have you ever read
regulated inside of a woman in the hopes
of get to questions okay in the hopes of
getting her pregnant I have not told you
I'm 30 you still can have you ever
rejected into a man's but I am the guy
I'm pregnant I have not quite so yeah
that's taking the long way home too if
you try to do that man great tune I'm
not coming in some guys but wait who I'm
not coming in some guys but ever
don't think you know not then you get
why I have the evidence that's a good
point
I like we instead I want to have
something to mail home to my wife has a
paper towel to wipe it off his stomach
that's a that's true man I mean that's
crazy mail in the mailbox oh yeah
man was take me back there when somebody
maybe doesn't feel well
you don't come home ago I'm gonna [ __ ]
this sad at her like yeah it's not a
sexy situation no no no and then when
somebody was sexually active and you met
this person and then you sort of see
them fade from the photograph it's uh
it's heartbreaking and it's weird and
then you just don't feel then there I
said this like my act when I do stand-up
I just there's not like an overshare
like there's no such [ __ ] thing now
you cruise if you're a comic your job is
to say things that have can't possibly
have been said ever before yeah you're
like a car that has as much gas as it
wants and doesn't know any of the rules
of the road I feel like make you cruise
yeah but you gotta know the rules where
before you break right but yeah I mean
you know that you Coltrane yes you know
all the rules I mean you know the book
you know the rule book every day I write
the book yeah but when you're out there
you're doing your thing but so tell me
this so I keep trying to when you get
there so you have a year where you don't
see your son when you bury or we were
just talking about boners
well he's I could wrap this up for you
real quick yeah so when somebody maybe
is depressed though you think yourself
the only thing that would make this
situation worse is if I lost my rib
there it goes oh yeah and then what's
the point of doing it if that's gonna
happen if it could have and then you
just get all up in your head what excuse
do you go with cuz I've been there man
we have sex I got a beautiful lady there
she's like two years yeah and my excuse
about girls that like maybe that I would
date was I was in a I was in a really
messed up situation this doesn't really
work if it works good on you
yeah and they all say the same thing
well you know if it was me I'm like okay
sure yeah and I'm already up in my head
because I led with it the last night the
cialis helped you out maybe that hit her
I haven't had sex that long since I was
a [ __ ] Tony Gwynn boy yeah
same gut yeah no yeah it was a line
drive that was all I know I've the whole
way yeah he's a hitter man yeah I'm
trying to think like if I could get a
base it was a Ricky Henderson's like
wall and a fly like that's that frozen
rope big ass time and that Gator dive in
a second
he would die I remember him he hit a
home run one time and he dove in a
second he's my favorite player of all
time really ever I saw him one time I
think any airport it was him or Barry
Sanders oh it was Barry Katz Ricky
Henderson man Ricky Henderson's the
all-time stolen base blonde you that
looks like Dirk Nowitzki good god man
Ricky Henderson always speaks in the
first person you know no II really his
name is Ricky Nelson Henny Henderson and
he's born in the back of a Cadillac yeah
and his mom loved Ricky Nelson I got to
interview him once and he and I just got
like the weirdest [ __ ] about him I could
gather some like everybody just threw
all like baseball [ __ ] Adam right yeah
I'm like something your mama some love
Ricky Nelson you know my mama loved her
he Nelson that you know that's why my
name is Ricky I'm like no I know I
didn't say that I'm like really I know
you're so fast like you might have been
born in the back of a car I was he goes
I was born in the back of a Cadillac no
yeah Nomar Garciaparra told me when he's
on the Red Sox Brooke he leads off the
game with a double and he's standing on
the second base shaking the dirt out of
his belt and the back says you know
Garciaparra with two of ours two peas do
and he goes yeah number five number five
and he turns around he's shaking the
dirt at his belt he does eyebrows I get
sexy goes Ricki hit a double and when
you get on the bus once it was full and
Mike Stanley goes make one of these
young guys moves you got tenure and he
goes Mike Stanton 18 years ultra he's
[ __ ] legit like the person that was
there told him to me so my boners work
now yeah thanks to a little orange pill
called tic I actually just take tic tacs
do you yeah I'd like to show myself
placebos
treat I go you know what I'm gonna take
out I'm gonna take it by agra and then I
just take a blueberry out of my
refrigerator I mean like pop mine [ __ ]
myself why do you have erectile
dysfunction for me is some of the
pornography you know I should be
steroids when I was younger than
sometimes I think it could be some
backlash from that no but um I mean it
could be but no no way but then I go
into the fact that is that the
pornography there's a lot of guys on
steroids that are [ __ ] right now yeah
yeah but I'm not one of those guys
that's a problem you a sex and love
addict because pornography is in there
right that's progressive addiction
that's weird I think he got progressive
to the point where like I need to really
take some time I have an extended period
of time away from it so I can let my
imagination work again in a comfortable
way interesting because I I've similar
situations when I was married and never
looked at it never cheated I didn't like
jackoff because like what if that's the
night like she shows interest in me
right I'm like oh I got diarrhea I can't
for this yeah so oh yeah you can't have
diarrhea forever I had diarrhea for
forever I had all kinds of stuff so I
don't know easy disease nothing and then
when I got divorced I'm like oh my
cuckold what the [ __ ] this is amazing oh
it's not because she's a horse cuz he
idolizes her why shouldn't she have this
bull it's so dark though is it at a
certain point I feel annoyed yeah it
becomes very because I realize I was out
of step meeting once and talking about
addiction versus progression progressive
addiction like gambling yeah it's a
progressive addiction it's not like
we're allergic to alcohol knee ology
starts before we take it right like if
you're allergic to fruit if you're
allergic like a fig you eat a fig and
your [ __ ] throat close your eyes shut
you puke done with FIGS yeah the end no
more figs alcoholics we're allergic
alcoholics and we're like where the [ __ ]
who opened that what is that right what
is that where is that why we need any
glasses just give me the [ __ ] bottle
or yeah we start puking we're like let's
get more after this yeah like we're
idiots well for me it was always the
next thing it was like well my thing
really was just I wanted to have a
little bit of cocaine you know in my
system has anybody ever had a little bit
of cocaine now do I sound like Norma
Donald is I'm in my to self conscious
like I feel like ever Mikey has anybody
ever really had well I don't think these
words of Eva these walls haven't even
had a lot of words I don't even in the
studio for like a month a little bit of
cocaine
got a good no McDonald's story I'd like
to hear you know I was probably there
you know they say guys on steroids the
side effect is increased libido but you
said maybe I did steroids as a kid I
thought I was like a 5 year old guy with
a tricep bar in the front yard they're
doing exercises for that big black lady
that beat up all the guys oh that's kisi
LaRon yeah you can name or whatever you
want but I'm an old chunk of coal from
Ontario I call her trouble I just call
her trouble
Kizzy that's awesome man
Kizzy yeah that's either so southern in
black or so northeastern Jewish yeah I
got a grandma hello darling its Kizzy
how are you so pornography became such a
probably you become desensitized a bunch
of became desensitized I think and alter
your dick does could you just keep
rubbing it well dude I was looking at
these magical you know I was looking at
a lot of these magical [ __ ] on the
internet and I was just turned out by it
you know and next thing you know they
got all these ladies and I would be
nervous most of the time also I would be
I would masturbate and have anxiety at
the same time because you see these
ladies you know in there some of them
are like whole like are you gonna live
ladies and for no no I'm talking about
on the internet you had anxiety looking
at a make-believe person who because I
worry yeah he's out of the business a
couple years yeah filming the scene you
know I worry about their health a lot of
times you got these your [ __ ] up like
that to me is like we're over the line
like we're like I hope she's okay yeah
that's like John Wayne Gacy [ __ ] these
kids cuz that love I love these you
check my crawlspace those kids they were
inoculated yeah they all got haircuts
it's great once we had June it's just
crew cuts every two weeks man I care for
these kids but this hand the Cask is a
well fed to catch a predator like I'm
here to save his life not one guy goes
I'm here to [ __ ] him are you his dad is
this cool cameras did I hit the fetish
jackpot cops oh my oh dude just just
just I'm here to [ __ ] them
man that's crazy man what kind of porn
did you watch
nothing real drastic I didn't think but
I know I mean if your dick is
desensitized to the friction from your
hand most of stuff I was watching was
probably you know a dull all adult and
then hold on let's just put a pin in
this for a second and maybe take that
part out
no I wasn't watching anything perverse
man you a mostly adult all adult he said
mostly I thought us at all but even
still like the fact that you quantify
that you're watching people 18 and up
[ __ ] his little 18 and up I believe you
every time I saw somebody even looked a
little bit young you know I would shut
it down and I would then I would uh what
was Nick going to say there I just think
he likes to avoid speaking in absolutes
so he said mostly at first but he
quickly correct him call me okay guys
are [ __ ] earlier 90% you I would you
eat you know what I'm better than him
sorry
yeah that's all right it's no good
though it's just for me a second
um but so yeah my thing was that I would
watch these women some were holding
their butts open and stuff and I would
be worried that people need to sit you
know you were gonna hit scolds that was
one of my biggest things I remember well
I don't want you to have a draft you
know as a kid yeah no I don't sleep near
that window there's a breeze coming
through there you know but if you hold
open your [ __ ]
oh there's gonna be quite a breeze yeah
that's dragging that's cold you may
catch your death I don't know man you
get email maybe you get aids from all
the [ __ ] in it I don't want to get AIDS
again and then I would start yeah I
would start researching if people had
AIDS and stuff and then it would get
just right I just I don't know I just
was concerned about the health of them
are you single married girlfriend I'm
dating a girl and I am not married I've
never been married when I was married
and cheat and um cuz you go you cheat
once you that's it you know it's not
like you work it off your record
yeah like now it's a misdemeanor now
it's gone because I had somebody write a
letter for me like but then once I
discovered pornography when I was single
yeah I was like holy [ __ ] this is a
whole new world and my friend then I go
out like I want to go on a couple dates
and he's like you know we're condoms I'm
like why
were you wearing condoms back then no
this like this year okay I'm like on
like who where do you think I'm going
yeah like condoms like I'm not [ __ ]
in you know why I don't you never know
it's like yeah but I'm not gonna be
presumptuous and like dr. drew would go
that's the most irresponsible take ever
and yeah love dr. Drew but it's like I'm
like what am I gonna get like if I get
like sit with like somebody has syphilis
like I'm gonna sit with some I'm we're
comics we're pretty good we can read a
room for our jobs so one on one like
fish in a barrel
yeah so if you're sitting across from
someone lady and she's like using the
salad tongs to scratch her [ __ ] box
during dinner you're like yeah it's a
red flag yeah that's bread crumbs right
but we also do a like s crouton country
that's croutons we also talked ourselves
out of it like she can't have anything
her dad's a dentist yeah she's from
Minnesota she's clean bro yeah her dad's
a doctor he's a chiropractor exactly
come on what you have there's a neck
brace with autographs on it obviously
she follows Poisson around the country
she told me she [ __ ] about you like
this do you think Sebastian Bach has
ever [ __ ] a woman in a neck brace on
it yes I don't know
alright ready yeah scuse me I was in
Saturday Night Live and I'm at a bar
downtown with a like a penthouse pet
like in New York City yeah you know
there's something about New York City I
can't quite put my finger on it the name
itself yeah it's too much why is that I
think it just should be New York but
it's New York City in New York yeah it's
too much I don't even soft boy your own
that really that's what I was trying to
do oh yeah about that name I just think
I'm batting cage aluminum bat ding New
York City New York yeah it's too much
it's too much as a double entendre yeah
both ways yeah in a bit of a palindrome
yeah I think it it anyway no it's not
actually it's not amount of pee a
country I think all of a sudden I think
I'm on a boat yeah that was kids he's
real name was actually spelled
onomatopoeia okay I love callbacks
so I'm downtown in this bar with like
this rocket ship standing next to me
like just it was nuts and Sebastian
barkos amen and we're both from Jersey
silly girl Jersey guys are just like all
right yeah there's a rest here and he's
flipping the hair and he goes your girl
and my girl tonight I'm like what he
said foursome he saying
yeah and it's sebastian bach's I'm like
whoa and he's like your girl and my girl
tonight exactly doing like that and I
look and at the bar is like a nine month
pregnant attractive woman holding like a
Perrier and she's like hey and to this
day I [ __ ] turn that down ah nine
months pregnant I could have just
induced labor oh yeah when everything's
working mmm you're my girl tonight do
what if you had started that labor you
could be a midwife man I would have been
I would have been and she breaks water
all over your taking balls that's gotta
feel good
see that kind of stuff makes me real
nervous why I don't know man yeah baby
the lady that likes squirts UH one lady
one time
are you autistic no the first two times
it was okay in the third time I just I
started getting nervous man she thought
you know well it was like kind of it was
like [ __ ] a bomb you know exactly and
that's what I didn't like you like The
Hurt Locker
you love bomb movies it was like Tuck
Everlasting it was like a couple of
scenes from Tuck Everlasting Wow it was
- my I like that particular act uh
because you can't fake it
yeah if they're squirting their [ __ ]
they've lost a [ __ ] mind
yeah it's like maybe it's best maybe all
I know is this person has left earth and
when they come back they're gonna go oh
my god your shades and that was another
thing to clean up is too much man it's
too much that's why I do all my sex in
the back of a u-haul you know Black &
Decker table saw and I do uh
circumcisions with a plan we neither
I feel of no McDonald I heard him on the
but guys go I hear people imitate him
you know I'm like I said [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm like oh no I mean
everything I'm mocking it I opened up
for Norma Jean of the casino and a
Cherokee Casino in Oklahoma this is a
while back and that we're playing in a
celebrity poker tournament that
right and he and the next day we're
standing around as a bunch of just not
attractive women in this room
Oklahoma yeah he said and he he goes he
goes yeah he goes man there's a lot of
hot chicks in here huh
and I'm thinking about John Wayne or was
that no one does norman sound like John
Wayne doesn't normally McDonough hot
chicks in here I love it and he go and I
was like I'm thinking well I'll you know
I'll accommodate nor McDonald you know
maybe he's getting older and he doesn't
know kind of how hot chicks are anything
anymore sawdust like yeah yeah
definitely our man a lot of hotties in
here you know and he goes [ __ ] no there
aren't
eh-oh chicks if ii water how long ago
was this
this probably eight years ago Norma
Donald is one of the most legendary
secretive cocksman of all time is he
really
Elle Macpherson like Wow oh yeah like
you're like wait what but then you look
at him you go yeah he's like this
nineteen fifties handsome man like a
movie star yeah like no I'm like if I
can shut up trust me like you look at
the guys at the bluest eyes you know
chunk of coal here but I think you owe
daddy an apology yeah so why don't you
just suck his thumb and lay on your back
yeah I don't wanna I don't know what his
game was what's fun do you think that
like I hate doing impressions of
hypotheticals I only told things that
actually like happened do an impression
you start to think about like what do
you have to use as we get older to
attract women you start to worry about
that kind of stuff no no I gotta trust
the compass man yeah
a guy there's this fighter I work with
and he's like let me just ask you
something like a black guy no no I say I
work with them well just trying to get
more racist by being completely
ambiguous Wow no it's gonna get an idea
of who it is like you're not giving me
any a guy one of the stories about
something else
yeah what am i ever like that's what a
wife does so there's a fighter I work
with in Spokane I was in Spokane I was
at the comedy club
it's called Spokane comedy club and I
was wondering why they didn't like name
it name it it was a Thursday but it was
crowded for a Thursday did you go krysta
you like what's the [ __ ] you need an
editor for your [ __ ] face oh yeah
you need an editor in the car with you
going nub cut that part out he didn't
give a [ __ ] about her french bulldog no
nails hair got it uh-huh blow dry a blow
bar great wait a what no it's not keep
going keep going
we had to be a Wendy's two o'clock on
Sunday thank you write it down let's
edit your face a lot of word counts some
people should be put in a word count me
certainly really
oh yeah it's awful that's my moat oh and
then on the phone you definitely chat
him and yesterday we talked to the phony
we're all it yeah that's my moat just
safety mechanism I like if I I keep you
out there it's like a chair but stiff
arm
but if I like you you're in here and
then I just want to like bathe you and
everything that's ever giving me
pleasure less Johnson & Johnson country
right there it is it's in New Jersey too
by the way is it really no more tears
yeah I loved it we used to using were
kids
yeah we used to put it all over each
other even when we weren't even at the
tub we loved Johnson & Johnson gone I
remember my sister for her birthday
one is just a gallon of Johnson &
Johnson and we would [ __ ] just wait
till our eyes burned and we would put it
all over each other we loved it it was
like the nicest thing we had in our
house it was a can of that or a jar it
wasn't a jaws of a plastic big can of
beans no need a can opener Mandy's like
what blue my keys should wash
everybody's hair in this [ __ ]
you like we loved it I we rubbed it all
over each other my sister a much we
loved it we love Johnson and Johnson man
and you rub me on your sister's body
well we rub it all over each other
there's just like a it was a [ __ ] it
was just a you were in a cult you know
to divert one year my mom for our birth
somebody's birthday I guess she didn't
have a bunch of money so she got us all
two liter sodas right everybody got
their own wall and dude I remember we
had so much fun shaking those things up
and just spraying each other she says
all her mine
oh and you guys it's probably loved it
though it was a function she was okay
she made us do it outside but I mean we
[ __ ] my sister had cherry 7up on her
for a month man and we load it off with
the lotion it's a it you can't have them
sweet without the stank did I grow up in
turpentine country do you know that why
do now yeah Covington Louisiana
turpentine was in this back when time
was king you know this is bad why was it
was an event to just get paint off the
[ __ ] well yeah and everybody hates it it
but it's like you know who hates it
people look down on it you've completely
and constructed that in your own brain I
think I don't think so nobody if you
have paint on your hands where's the
turpentine period that's the thing
everybody doesn't everybody's like oh
[ __ ] turpentine and to know you need
nobody is like nobody thinks about
turpentine at all right it's a it's a
trigger hippie song I know okay well
that's the problem is that nobody's
thinking about it well yeah nobody's
thinking about baby aspirin until you
have a baby need a favor I think it
Mills around on the back here here it
does yeah yeah like the other liquids
mill around back there gasoline you need
it milk it'll be you know I mean through
two days I'll need it you know what
liquids are milling around in the back
of our heads think about it water always
and that's an SS City because water is
right there inside of us telling us yeah
you know I'm just up on a shelf looking
down like and you know what I'm coming
in yeah eggnog coming around you know
yeah grape juice not really as much
maybe you're a child yeah you know it's
amazing as you get older you're like
this is [ __ ] horrid yeah but were a
kid grape juice was king
man that was cotton I just remembered a
bit that I have to write down because I
was like I gave my son like grape
medicine for his cough I'm like well
this might have codeine in it so she'd
probably drink the whole bottle first
yeah check it out yeah back in I'm like
I spilled it all over and they give me
another one then I realized great for
kids and medicine doesn't take like
grape it tastes like purple
they've mastered with purple taste like
if you eat a grape and have like great
and hop medicine like no but I got a now
and later a banana now and later and
that it that WAAFs a [ __ ] banana
there's a banana taste in there
yeah the grape they just that's what
purple tastes like yeah they want that
purple yeah they want that drink they
want that drink man oh my sure do you
think that
you think getting high is better if
you're african-american or black is your
high better yeah I think it's
socio-economic not color yeah I think if
you're broke is [ __ ] I think that highs
nice yeah they give you a rich it's like
I'm high and it's the same people and I
got a view of the ocean this is kind of
stupid yeah
but Dave you're broke like think about
the highest you've been when you were
poor you like this there's an alternate
reality I'm really dancing at this
wedding yeah yeah you can lose yeah yeah
cuz when you're high yeah that's a good
point man that's a really good point
when you're high and you're poor it
takes you out of being poor it's like
anything is a possibility for a little
while I'm just I gotta get this down
that's purple uh when you are and when
you aren't and when you are rich then
you start to get high you're like [ __ ] I
might be missing out on opportunities or
something you know I think when you're
rich and you get high you're like what
are they [ __ ] talking about over
there yeah I love me how to [ __ ] me yeah
I'm gonna go over and cause the scene
yeah if you're broke it's like look I go
to meetings and they're like well i
drink as my [ __ ] my father fingered
me in front of my sister and this I'm
like I drink cuz I [ __ ] love getting
[ __ ] up and I keep going because the
more [ __ ] up I get and then it crosses
terminal velocity and I go if I keep
drinking I'll pass out and it'll be done
that's it when I was 14 I had a rum and
coke 13 at a rum and coke at a wedding
and I like apparently I'm breakdancing
can you been dancing since then I'm a
[ __ ] breakdancer do you feel
like a deer a demon no I work for the
Lord sir yeah I do indeed I'm a conduit
yeah I'm a conduit I'm an instrument the
st. Francis of Assissi that's that's the
prayer I look at and go okay I get it
man I don't do a great job but no
supposed to be a condiment you are a
conduit that's what brought us together
man is God and ruin we're just [ __ ]
rubble of what the with the higher power
the universe is on the Lord's Detroit I
don't think you're that bad yet because
you're on the men you're more like this
the Riverwalk in San Antonio I like what
the [ __ ] is going on and you're like oh
look gondolas oh okay they got a plan
around Charles Barkley said all the
women down here are fat don't get the
[ __ ] well there's business
yeah Popovich to her I like it
we're gonna let's do a couple of calls
you want to pipe some man Nick talk
about some things I'm about to pee my
pants are you how do you say gang gang
gang gang boy that's it
yes it just means you know that we're
gonna do this together and we're not
gonna be alone you know and it me true
[ __ ] rich people as well usually what
about you but you got more money than
half the people to say gang gang mmm I
don't think I do really three
[ __ ] ain't Dabba Dabba was
Sweeney's name is debo cuz there goes
that ball again that Baba I knew a boy
named no Dante and his mom is the best
thing I've ever heard his mother I
bought that I mean you got the White
Album probably so go but whatever but
his mother put she knew he was gonna be
misbehaving so she put no in the front
of his name how great is that I don't
know of anything it's it's good no Dante
it's sad good it's perfect but I don't
know how a society of named wise if will
ever top an Frannie yeah yeah and for
any hardaway well there's no that's the
only one I don't know of but like what -
like I'm not sure how and ferny yeah
that's I wish I named my kid Anthony and
I'm not joking at all and [ __ ] a
pretty hey max
go [ __ ] your max I gotta Anthony yeah I
got a max nephew and yeah my son's name
is Meredith means Lord of the sea
it's his first name yeah Meredith Daniel
what do y'all call him death I don't
Meredith Daniel I call him Meredith am i
Maki when he's like people called Maki
mm-hmm
and but I'm like nah that's that's a
tight name and I talked about on stage
I'm like if he was a black slot receiver
that was a game Daniel oh wow there's
like Meredith more like just a hand like
a Rick Fox looking brother like you see
this [ __ ] named Meredith
Meredith more name is Meredith
that's [ __ ] central Meredith well I
feel like TMI yeah oh sorry
let's go back to that moment this over
that year you don't see your son name a
good call it was longer than axes we saw
each other
piecemeal and I had to get well first
yeah I went back to a like March 14th
last year and I didn't drink I was just
[ __ ] ill man I was sick my head was
[ __ ] up I was roiling around I was
depressed I was sad I was sadness was
something I never addressed I'm [ __ ]
sad
and I needed a welcome chip and I had
been in the program may 5th 1998 I went
to my first meeting but I never got a
sponsor I never like did the work and
they say at the end of you keep coming
back it works if you work it yeah I
never work that I never wrote out
resentments I never took my inventory
like my defects of character like really
looked at them and it's amazing the more
I did the work the more people in my
life started talking to me finally the
way I wanted them to talk to me mmm but
they didn't change I changed yeah you
know so ya know exactly when I talkin
where I was at a meeting in the
Palisades and I for some reason I got
like this fire me I said I gotta go
right off my resentments now I'm like
wait to the end of the meeting I go I'm
gonna wait one more second and write
what who waited the speaker goes there's
a universe and me and that's [ __ ]
impossible I'm like whoa Wow
now I can go but I waited and I heard
that before I left
there's the universe and me and that's
impossible oh they're holy [ __ ]
so bright I'm writing out my resentments
and I'm mad at so-and-so for keep and I
put it in quotes keeping me from seeing
my son and then I kept writing why did I
just put that in quotes because one of
my defects of characters I've never
given 100% of anything ever it just
athletics stand-up fighting girls
meeting people everything always come
really easy to me and the one thing I
gave 100 at was my marriage
and so that caved in on my first
defected character of an insatiable need
irrational need for validation I get
applause for going to my office
people go [ __ ] yeah let's do it
every single time right so the marriage
failing fed the like nah I need more
validation and why give 100% cuz look
what just happened and I just was out of
the marriage long enough that I was
actually six feet tall and I was tall
enough cuz the only that 1% I didn't do
is just go to their house and ring the
bell and say I'm sorry for the stepdad I
put a lot on your plate man and I did
and I started crying and he held me like
a baby he held me dude oh my god put a
lot in your plate I miss my son I still
know what his hair smells like and he
goes it's okay man and he [ __ ] held
me like a baby like I'm in debt to the
student really this guy's got a problem
I got a [ __ ] problem
yeah
I'd take care of my problems this man
loved me and I put [ __ ] on his plate I
wonder whatever a sincere apology and I
had to make an apology to the mom and it
was legit like man I just I didn't show
up and that's the thing I hate most
about my father
my father was in the household my father
did not show up just right there's
different angles and stuff yeah optics
as you would say yeah he was there but
not there but he was I'm elements but my
insatiable need I need him to throw
catch a different way a different
everyday like yeah I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
up right it's me you need yeah you need
everything you need him to notice you in
hers and feasibly sustain what I did I
need them yeah nobody can sustain what I
need and I need them to read my mind
it's the one I don't believe me - [ __ ]
along and y'all saw anything - tell them
what you're thinking is they should
already know what you and I'm a lonely
person but everything I love to do I do
alone stand-up wrestling I love to fish
when I paddleboard and I fish from a
[ __ ] paddleboard I love to drive and
then I didn't see what I do alone and
that's when I'm my happiest cuz I can't
talk there's no talking alone on a
paddleboard we have a [ __ ] four pound
bass towing you passed Duke's yeah yeah
you gotta come here it's that crazy I'd
love to come out there
I never fists off a paddleboard before
it's you only eat [ __ ] for about two
months then when I saw my son and then I
made amend in a minute men's and I see
my son he's like this beautiful if you
could just time stop life and meet you
two years from now or like meet your
your girlfriend or I don't know who's in
your life that you're closest with but
if you just like two years Bert and then
two years later you're the proper age
and you get to see what that person's
like as though all the wonders that you
would have Wow but it happened and
you're like and then I had to go back to
the stepdad go this kid's got incredible
qualities and as you're doing well I see
you man and I love you for it and I'm so
grateful and then you go but I also see
the basement I see that hurricane door I
see the first one like oh I built this
[ __ ] from scratch like he can't
shake that and then they little by
little the thing is if you ever if your
listeners were ever like away from a kid
for a while you cannot talk you may not
you are not allowed you may not talk
[ __ ] about another parent and every time
you do you sink smaller and small
yeah I had to be six feet tall again
after the cooky I went to a mental
hospital twice the only reason I take
the bed it said The Improv the next
night I said I can't do that to Rita
yeah that's it and I had a great show
and then a meeting the neon Sunday
morning and then a Monday morning
wrestling practice was like clear and I
go well that way somehow I was crazy but
I was in the [ __ ] place downtown and
Keiser yeah I know any money they could
take and if you have a kid that you see
you may not defend yourself you can't
talk [ __ ] about anybody you just have to
be silent for what you don't learn [ __ ]
when you're talking and that kid will
teach you more and I'll tell you more
[ __ ] that's untrue and you just sit
there like oh you just take it yeah
because your child's talking and feels
comfortable enough to actually share
[ __ ] about you that he would like to
scream in your [ __ ] face even if it's
not truthful and eventually the truth
don't move man the truth doesn't move
and little by little by little by little
the kids start saying things like I
remember you play Chet Baker for me when
I was a baby and like now I'm the only
one in my class then those who Chet
Baker is like I bet that hit you in the
art huh you're like good okay and then
you reel then they just you know you
could say things to your kid I said to
my son I go you know there's a guy in
California he's watching the Sun go down
there's a guy in Japan watching the Sun
come up there's a guy out in outer space
he don't see the Sun at all all three of
those guys that's reality and it is
reality
yeah so you just got to be aware that
there's a guy in Japan there's a guy a
Malibu this guy in space and just that's
all i'ma say a lot of perspectives going
on same time little by little they just
they figure [ __ ] out they know do you
think your son do you ever worry that he
doesn't that do you feel like he loves
you enough yeah it's it's astounding
it's it's the most powerful thing I've
ever had in my life okay so there's a 15
year old son that's 6 feet tall
wants to be President United States as
he did when he was a baby I mailed him
an index card and I wrote is housing a
right or a privilege examined before you
answer and I get in the next card in the
mail a month later and he wrote yes I'm
like damn it
like he's Bobby Kennedy level right yes
were you amazed at how me I'm amazed by
the way your son is M Ryan Adams yes
dude I was doing a show it's Paul
McCartney oh then Africa and met Bryan
Adams at a yogurt bar at a breakfast bar
is that what they call it yeah here
we're just no are you amazed that
children this is a parent because I've
never been a parent are you amazed that
kids can like you know do they bounce
like just how resilient they are and how
much they bounce back and what their own
actions are like like yes but it was
also my resentment was there was nothing
about back from I'm sort of omitted and
the goal I felt the goalposts moved like
well now's not a good time a lot of that
that must have been hard for you to like
just hold on hold and I want to think I
went to a mental hospital twice and that
was on top of the marriage on top of the
job that made me insane like so you're
being gas lit in three different
directions and you're like the odds of a
[ __ ] job a wife and an ex all saying
the same thing to me are zero yet it's
happening and they can't all be wrong
when you were a kid your mom goes so
everyone's wrong but you yeah and you go
oh but then as an adult you look at that
[ __ ] you go yes yeah I'm [ __ ]
positive it's an impossible confluence
of [ __ ] at the Andrea Gail Bray you're a
Gail yes
but then I also realize there's a
language I speak that don't commit
doesn't doesn't convey don't go through
the UN headset people in I tried to work
on my [ __ ] damn and leave it out on that
note home all [ __ ] outcast you're
troubled man you're interesting yeah no
I love that you said on the phone he
goes I've always dug you you seem like a
real strange dude yeah I'm not troubled
but not trouble like I mean but it's odd
I think I'm told I think it's love it
you got really funny defensive play yeah
I did I get nervous and that trouble
trouble they [ __ ] trembled like a
math problem well that I'm letting you
walking around your [ __ ] fingers and
kids you know he's [ __ ] troubled what
trouble [ __ ] troubled if you were one
of the Wet Bandits dude based on that
voice which one would you be the tall
skinny guy or would you be part of the
Wet Bandits
the Wet Bandits of the guys that attack
Macaulay Culkin in that when his parents
went out of town I'd be uh
because it deters the vo does he really
oh no it is the vo for the one years
which one we're not which guy - gets hit
in the [ __ ] face and beaten up - I
want to be first yeah neither but I have
to would you be
I'd be Pesci more fun to play yeah no I
I don't know will you be the guy that
leaves a faucet someone because he won't
see a claymore you beep s users in there
it's a tough one
I'd be the [ __ ] idiot who leaves a
faucet on that thing but nothing I want
to play except played like oh yeah a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and dicks I've become
Rutger Hauer yeah get Jay Mohr really
Rutger Hauer that's great that is the
Hitcher I'm sure
I'm Michael Landon fan though do you
ever work with him know that calls are
coming I love him when he hit a call man
will hit a call let's hit a call and
then you have erectile dysfunction
because you do things that gives you
erections
you think I'm troubled you just let me
know if you go I've got I mean I'm
thrown ick I think Jays may have me no
come on you kidding me no I don't really
think you're Arnold thing I don't know
man you are uncomfortable yeah yeah my
comfortable all right I get
uncomfortable well you did say that I
see you say that I understand up like my
you know your default setting
uncomfortable yeah I like that you share
that on stage because it's truthful yeah
that's that's you yeah I think I just I
don't know I guess I just get afraid
sometimes if you're uncomfortable or
afraid around me that's just you
yeah sealing up and like a balloon boy
bubble cuz well I appreciate that and
yes sir you called and you say you know
the first thing I want you to know is
that I don't think you could say
something that would I don't think he
could be rude yeah the last part of your
text was and none of this was meant to
be rude and I hope it didn't come
because I read from the bottom up and I
just read that one part and I called you
I go I don't think you're capable of
being rude to me because I know your
heart you're just a great you're a good
person you're a great guy thanks man I
appreciate you saying that I can help
you with more comfortable I can help you
with this fear yeah well yeah and it's
based on nothing it's not based in
reality it's not based on anything
you've actually experienced you've never
been in a room with three guys I mean
like this is where they [ __ ] pay me
now and broke my jaw yeah it's all the
construct of your conditioning and
bullsh output off my foot no it's fine I
don't care I mean I don't care about
general my car off like I just I'm
trying to
to you and think about what you're in
like feel what you're saying you know
and try and see where it lands like
inside me at the same time you know I
have to pee my eyes out book alright
it's called all those bits but this carl
has been waiting right alright let's do
a call you want to do one and we'll get
a poor person we can um if you wanna
this has been great I can help you with
that fear for real no I'm 100% serious
man I really need never had it's weird
I'm the outlier I know that yeah maybe
that's what it is maybe not trouble you
just an outlier of everything
certainly here's Alexander APO this is
Alexander and Largo Florida just want to
call and say hey man share some share
some good news with you my lady and I
are signed up to run our first 5k race
on April 7 that in writing and yeah
we're gonna be celebrating with you in
Tampa that same night so even more
exciting that did manage once they were
out there getting active you know
getting after gonna be life survivors
you know I mean we'll see it Rock
Brothers brewing brah Rock Brothers
brewing come see Theo well no I didn't
know that that guy was uh and when he
first started I thought that man was
honestly into men upper 30s Peschel e
largo florida lot of assumptions man
yeah and is he doing a 5k with his band
I'm system I was an [ __ ] oh he's off
the line I I said I was a dick like oh
and he goes it's exciting I'm like is it
and then I went you know what they're
doing it together it's [ __ ] cool
because people that run like marathons
they got intimacy issues man you think I
know you gotta get ready to do like your
run every day then you run for two hours
alone then you come home it takes an
hour to shower you got to eat the
specific food that nobody else is
allowed to touch and then you know then
then maybe somebody leaves for work yeah
like this guy's doing it with the old
lady
so you think doing it with the old lady
is that they're together they're
together and they got trained together
they're gonna do and they talk about
what they're doing that's good stuff so
that's good stuff
oh yeah what there's no negative there
all right all right all right I'm sorry
to a long-feared sit down I had to sit
down a PHP so bad you know it's I I sit
down sometime when I pee in the morning
and if I pee in the middle of the night
but I that's cuz you had a boner
no you know the only reason you get an
erection in your sleep but you don't pee
you in your bed is that true yeah you
can't pee when you in a boner I wet the
bed
no jokes I was probably 32 years old
I well I I'm sorry and I went to bed I
was a bed-wetter
but not like that yeah but I went to bed
from the top of my dresser oh that was
my first joke ever I can't believe this
[ __ ] I was 16 I was on my first job -
that's a [ __ ] great I'm athletic
captain in the miniature golf - yeah I
missed last year I was hit by a windmill
and I'm a bed-wetter I mean everybody
but I do it from the top of my dresser
that's so good thought my first five
minutes was and then I saw a tape of it
and it was like watching like another
country's parliament talk like what the
[ __ ] was he span the despatch-box look
across at mr. cosgrove the fine
gentleman from the he didn't burrow and
eat oh yeah yeah I'm like what I had my
five minutes I knew what it was in my
head and I watched it I didn't know what
I didn't understand what I was saying
Wow s-sir starting with me I've never
heard that a webapp
I wet my bed my whole life I mean most
of my childhood was constantly because
then I had to take a pill cuz they came
out with a pill were you armed
you took this pill from the doctor and
you wouldn't wet the bed when that came
out finally I could go sleep at friends
houses cuz I always had to be the kid
who was up all night walking around your
house loitering or I had to be the kid
who you know was some delicate ecosystem
you grew up in and your dad was just not
around yeah my mom had to do all of it
and you were aware of how much your mom
did yeah your fears from the childhood
it's the fear of I can't upset this
apple cart
I see the delicate nature I see this
ecosystem I can't run through this
garden with boots on yeah and there
would be hell to pay but there was never
held to pay with you your mom was
incredibly gentle with you and she saw
you like you know she saw you and she
didn't laugh I saw you say that in the
teaser what a lot to laugh at but you
knew she knew but with your dad's
absence and with siblings they would
catch a baton and for some reason you I
mean you got your fair share but it was
disproportionately it was them not you
hmm yes or no only say yes or no no you
got most of the beatings I think
everybody got decently is one of the
other body
it's not true because somebody doesn't
[ __ ] around so don't get any beatings
how many kids yeah I don't remember this
good question how many kids are your
four kids I was in odd response
how many kidding hear from somebody I
remember there was a small person bad
hair in the pecking order I was number
two I had a brother those two years
older than me and then two sisters there
were two years of beatings from him too
because he had to take out the
aggression yeah and he wasn't neither
one of us four good fighters but you
well he was a lot better than you were
two years is an eternity witness ten
years old
yeah his arms were heavier than mine so
you had to live in fear of that so you
were on eggshells on the way to school
in school on the way home from school in
the house we're supposed to be safe and
sound and your comrade your number-one
guy your go-to guy is the one that's
gonna kick the [ __ ] at you probably the
most cuz he can't find anybody he can't
beat anybody up except you yeah that'll
mean oh wait now that's true that'll
mean God carry fear yeah maybe that's
your mom pass I'm still alive she's
still alive good yeah she's on yeah and
that is very conflicting emotions what
about your dad they're both alive they
are both my dad's Paul Reiser and the
other guy my two dads no boat the other
guy with the moustache nobody knows the
name both my parents are alive they're
still together they're in Jersey and I
uh I just yeah I just my dad I just
seemed to annoy but that's how he just
was really and now I sent him a long
email once like let me tell you
something because I realized I asked my
father in the back of my book no wonder
my parents drank just like a
questionnaire to give your dad or your
son or your uncle or whatever the
answers will blow your mind like these
are not the people you know like what's
the best part about having a kid what's
the best part about having a son versus
a daughter what's the hardest part about
raising his son how is it different
when's the proper time to have the birds
and the bees when you go to bed
are you ever done being a parent mmm and
my father's answers I gave it to him
like two years ago for some reason and
not when the book came out the answers
[ __ ] shook me man it was like when
you were born basically like where I was
born is the greatest day of his life and
it still is feels no joy I'm like sure
I've never seen this guy have joy in my
life he reads books when he gets home
from work it's
a time there was TV they go to bed
repeat yeah and my dad was never
affectionate so I always made a vow that
I would always show affection and always
be present my grandfather wasn't like a
big deal he was like president of Revlon
he was a band leader he ran for Senate
Revlon you having a hair care makeup all
oh wow and then he was a perfumer then
he started in Britain that made his own
company and then so my father just
explained like basically like this guy
was kind of a son of a [ __ ] and he
treated us he wrote I remember that he
treated us as adjuncts instead of
children like just you know that we
acquired the ping-pong table room over
here like it's like no I'm John and your
oldest I run track at Rutgers so it felt
like buddies did it feel like buddies no
it was demanding like he was a he was a
compiler like he was uh he was a Nixon's
uh cabinet he was on Watergate er no he
was on the up-and-up he's not stupid I
can spy on people that might be against
you come on man I'm from Jersey man
that's straight Whittier [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah he's a clean water Gator I
have a sister he wasn't a water Gator
he's on the council for the aging he was
in the cabin a special guy yeah he was a
[ __ ] Marilyn Monroe and Bobby at the
same time your father did know sure so
my dear
Whittier yeah yeah I love all the things
we talk about - look I'm telling you I
said how many times the universe
happened us on the shoulder yesterday on
the phone I said to you so my
grandfather was like just not warm and
my father vowed to be like really warm
so what I perceived is like an absence
of heat procedures warmth was no it was
warmth because he didn't have anything
to go by there's no diorama or any study
and go this is how you treat a child
warmly because he didn't know it right
so everything here like he always played
catch with me he never ever ever my life
said no that didn't sound like a big
deal but it's to a guy that's insatiable
like me my wrestling matches in Boonton
New Jersey of Route 23 in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere where toothless
hillbillies are sitting next to their
wives and their kids and whatever like
just he I don't that old joke you know
yes my sister wife or whatever always
went on the road wrestling matches
started [ __ ] sick sativa way in there
at 6:00 a.m. you guys are close I didn't
know it at the time because I was too
busy with an alcoholic brain as a kid
like what's with this guy oh yeah this
guy what's with this guy what's with
this guy is he quit his job in the city
so he was home with us more Wow and he
wrote that all out and I was and I just
wrote him back like I owe you an apology
every time I've ever written cousin
gasping for air time a Saturday Night
Live book I'm like this guy never gave
me affection and this I'm like I'm
mortified that I ever wrote this about
and all those questions are in the back
of your book I could send her to my mom
or something no wonder my parents drank
yeah hey you'll be you you have to
because her answers and I need her
answers you will get her answers but my
father and sent his still two years
later and I didn't expect them which is
good taxes I was [ __ ] I was low when I
got that [ __ ] in the mail I just needed
it I was alone in my apartment like
scream crying like ah
and then my housekeeper comes in I might
get the bug out like we don't have
Windex oh my god no it's why you think
I'm crying because I can't see out of
the windows man yeah I love you at the
Farley Merle
yeah man bring men in Brady Mathews
painted this for me now is his first one
well Brady Mathews needs to hear this
story and then we'll go tell Milo more
stories
yeah well jump on more stories in just a
second David telling I shared an office
it's Saturday Night Live if you want to
make sure nothing gets done put the two
of us at an office like Paula get a box
set of Otis Redding that Lorne gave him
for his birthday and he cut a hole where
the mouth was and put a cigarette in it
and lit it like that was two weeks of
[ __ ] laughter like how long does the
cigarette laughs one of them go faster
we're like he's actually smoke we
weren't well so far Lee comes in on a
rewrite night there's no reason for
Farley to be in the building he was the
most beautiful man I ever met my life
ever
my grandfather my other grandfather read
my mom's dad Maurice Ferguson he was he
was the one man that saw him he was the
most beautiful man ever and and Chris
right behind him and Chris wasn't sober
to two years I was there it was had his
[ __ ] together and he was you know in a
van down by the river at Sun yeah and he
comes in he goes what are you guys doing
and me and Dave Attell go we'll give you
a hundred dollars to take a [ __ ] out the
window oh yeah well we said at the same
time like creepy twins come play with us
Danny will pay 100 he
yes and out what we were doing and our
answer at the same time he's from
Brooklyn I'm from Jersey he's Jewish
I'm Catholic like I will give you $100
like decadence like we were singing a
song the other two [ __ ] out the window
and he goes give her the money first and
we're like oh [ __ ]
patent pockets bro and including I'm not
exaggerating making lunch baby four
dollars in coins it was exactly a
hundred dollars and so he takes the
paper money Chris Farley puts it in his
pocket and then reaches across my desk
which is against the window the longest
way you could go and [ __ ] the strong
[ __ ] man lifts that [ __ ] tilts
the desk and the coins again a cartoon
ding-ding-ding into his pocket like
tingling like stacks of quarter stacks
of like ding ding ding ding ding ding
it was amazing drop the desk open that
giant ass window goes up on the window
ledge and rest the window on the back of
his neck facing in the building oh wow
is the 17th floor yeah he could fall to
his death in any moment especially at
his weight risk
he's very graceful man he was at no risk
of lead he have long legs no he was just
like a football player and he just had
incredible bow you see him do cartwheels
and [ __ ] and flips he was great the only
thing in the building was like his nose
his hands that were on his knees and the
snot bubble coming out of all the
holding just his head against that
window well yeah he's balancing on the
ledge as well right but it became
obvious and they do tell the story on
stage it became obvious immediately
they're critical that's a pop he'd have
to [ __ ] at all but he had the money man
he always delivers and the deals a deal
but he always delivers so you're doing
that body Tetris at that point I love
you marry you you start [ __ ] playing
Jenga with yourself Brook cause you
gotta find a turd in your body that's
true though just moving around yeah I
mean you're doing things yeah that's
when you get the diarrhea with the
stomachache you're like I can move this
bubble here so that's when you still
house when I need that shitty piece that
comes down makes it right and come down
again yeah the one that [ __ ] up your
whole game that a little hitter you need
that ball so like the windows rattling
from effort like this
he's purple and he's it's Farley's go
like in it and is he saying I'm also to
make you guys laugh at this you can't
he's insatiable that way he can't and
after like a minute which is a long time
when a guy's above the skating rink yeah
like if you ever see a fake one Fig
Newton without the Newton yeah one of
those like that size that shape it was
like square shape oh yeah and it was
thin oh yeah I'll guess consistency felt
like the snow through the window behind
them fell from his ass mmm in the window
onto my [ __ ] desk that's a Detroit
dove right there
there what he wipes his ass with his
hand there's no paper oh we don't write
we don't write yeah are you doing
nothing in there but [ __ ] I watch him
smoke I Diamond push-ups and I call
escorts and [ __ ] boy Lee Webb says
with his hand it goes ahh
it's touch doing like a zombie walk and
starts chick chasing in quotes cuz he's
gone living a zombie walk me and Dave
Attell are hauling her ass down these
hallways but like in scooby-doo he's
always right [ __ ] behind she's going
his eyes are all the way in the back of
his head so we know how we can see and
he went from like haha to like oh no
like terrifying
like I fought a harbor heights Mexican
Mafia gangbangers on PCP and he wouldn't
go down I'm like oh this is great
I thought that like right between the
chin and formulas [ __ ] middle of his
eyebrow to like his bottom lip just but
but and I'm like a minute in you go this
is a horror movie and I'm not like I'm
getting tired and he buggy near you am i
but like somebody [ __ ]
Mitch Mullane he gets out of his car and
beats him up and the whole set Mitch
Mulaney like apparently just fought in
Oakland his whole life it was amazing
rest in peace brother saved my life so
far Lee's chasing us around there's a
hallway going to Lauren's office that's
a single file only Lorne Michaels
yeah Lauren green actually he took over
the show for a while did he really
no you just mentioned Michael Landon so
jump on that I love Michael Landon I
okay
have you told them now well I didn't get
my mom almost met him one time at the
fairgrounds but
we're gonna get into this on mine let's
start more stories with this okay
because this ties right into everything
I was just saying about your home okay
fascinating he was the ideal he was the
guy oh yeah it even the pajamas that
were the whole body red pajamas you're
like see that's what a man wears oh he
was prince henry he was Prince Henry
Prince Harry Prince Harry he was our you
know he was our yeah yeah yeah he was
estee lauder he was somebody you know he
was the big deal
I tell and I had a single file only and
I'm like I am I am 11 months removed
from college wrestling so I'm like and
this [ __ ] right next to me
Asuna hobos Dave Attell and he's like oh
I'm like neither one of us are giving it
up and I'm on the bookshelf side and it
hits my shoulder and my shoulder comes
out of the socket goes around me like a
grandma taking her bra off at the table
yeah it felt like I just went around my
body and if you're not sure you've been
knocked out it's like I'm not sure if I
napped or not you did cuz there's no it
like no I didn't nap like I don't know
if I napped like then you'd surpass that
yet if your legs and I just get [ __ ]
knock yes yes you did and I'm standing
I'm laying on my back and Farley in the
[ __ ] and he's like huh and I'm like um I
go [ __ ] you Farley I broke my [ __ ]
joke I'm like putting it on like really
act and I made myself cry and he goes
are you okay and he stands up I just got
up and I ran out of that [ __ ]
building and I jogged home and I got
under the covers it was like the most
amazingly funny the most impossible
thing the most frightening thing and I
like fooled like a beautiful man into
thinking I was hurt like that hurt me
worse than anything he's like are you
okay like when he stopped being a zombie
it was a heartbreaking I just [ __ ]
want to throw myself in front of a cab
but that's but it's almost perfect man I
can imagine at that moment you're under
the covers and you created all of these
all of these things happen and you're
filled with all these feelings you're
filled with excitement
laughter fear chicanery because you guys
created this crazy thing the the vision
tom foolery and rumpus the vision that
somebody got [ __ ] on the vision that you
know hurt and all of that it's like an
annual rate we'll probably just save
like sleep comfortably
that's an enormous event but it just
shows how many feet
you have to have sometimes an alcoholic
to be filled with to be able to just oh
it was an overload it was too many
feelings right but the one that got me
was that are you okay yeah that [ __ ]
to this day I get if I think about it
long enough I'll [ __ ] cry like that's
a beautiful beautiful man like there's a
reason you mentioned his name and people
know oh my god like yeah you think you
know but you don't know but I'm glad you
know what you know yeah but he was the
most beautiful man I ever met in my life
not named Maurice yeah yeah I'm trying
to think of the most beautiful man Oh
arse as always I mean growing up it was
Michael Lannon and as an adult I haven't
chosen but when I was young it was
Michael right across anybody I'm right I
know you are and I'm glad you're but um
I can't [ __ ] with Michael Landon nobody
I mean Deacon Jones I don't know that is
get the [ __ ] in Philadelphia get over
76ers we're gonna wrap it up um Bobby
Sixers know will go to more stories how
about yeah yeah we'll go over two more
stories to j2j Moore's podcast you'll be
able to catch us on there Jay I just
want to thank you so much man for coming
into super I love your brother I see you
I can't look him in the eye when I say
it because I don't want you to be
uncomfortable but I do that's that man
you're you are the absolute guy like I
can't wait for your future like you're
the funniest [ __ ] guy I'm like I have
to just do this podcast mine meaning
mine and then you wanted me to be on
yours I'm like yeah let's break bread
anytime anyplace bro I appreciate some
crack some [ __ ] skulls out there
yeah means a lot that I'm a huge fan and
thank you for entertaining us I'm a
strange guy and for being here yeah man
you're strange man you're not troubled
though no I'm not troubled I'm aware of
my troubles which I think negates it
yeah it's like you're an Indiana Jones
in your own where's my whip
yeah where the [ __ ] is my whip always I
hate snakes
oh man I appreciate you yeah thanks bud
hey Kizzy if you can hear this come [ __ ]
with it thank you guys so much for being
here this episode happy Easter to you or
Happy Passover or happy you know atheism
if you're into that if you're into the
you know if you out there you know
juggle on the butt
Devils ball bag and you like being out
there like that you know we just you
know the full moon is your only friend
and that's then that's the best that's
for you too and I hope you enjoy
yourself and I hope you got some candy
from a rabbit or I hope you do but I'm
going to spend spend this weekend in
Louisiana and I just wanted to say thank
you guys this was our first guest that
we had in the studio and you know I'm
just I'm hopeful I'm excited for doing
more and I'd love to know any feedback
that you guys have drop a comment on
YouTube
constructive criticism please let's try
and you know just keep it you know let's
try and serve our criticisms in a
healthy manner and in a helpful manner
if we can all so I gotta let you guys
know about our star flow star flow is
little the location for fans trying to
link up and get closer to their favorite
celebrities so sometimes you don't want
to be a peeping tom you know you don't
want to hide out in a in um you don't
want to hide out in Giselle's trash or
you know or hiding out an egg in a
dumpster by our house so that's why you
go to star flow and you get that direct
celebrity interaction you know it
provides a hub for consumers to access
their favorite talents and celebrities
and exclusive content and only seconds
think about seconds there went some it's
available in the App Store or at Star
flow calm it stays out of that sell your
information secondary market it's a safe
place where you and celebrities and and
and and brands and everything can
coagulate and touch each other on the
shoulder you know what I'm saying it's
about users creators and content check
it out star flow calm or star flow on
the App Store and we'll have the link
below in the YouTube and on the iTunes
thank you guys again so much this is our
first guest and we hope for many more
thank you patreon for your patience and
support helping us get into the studio
and and I hope you guys have a good one
man be good of yourselves you probably
deserve it